- Today we're gonna talk about Disney+.
This was actually a really
wildly requested video.
So many of you guys have been Tweeting me,
leaving me comments asking me
what are my thoughts on Disney+.
Am I going to subscribe?
What shows am I watching?
And what do I think.
And obviously I'm a huge Disney fan.
It's something that so
many of us grew up with
and just the nostalgia factor
of Disney+ alone is amazing.
A huge thank you to Disney
for sponsoring this video.
When I first logged in to Disney+,
it was just like this wave of emotions,
and I saw so many shows that I had watched
when I was younger.
For example, one of the
shows that I recently watched
that was from my childhood,
I remember so distinctly
watching this old version
of Shaggy Dog with my family,
and it was weird watching it
because I had the same feelings that I had
when I was younger.
So it was kind of bring
back all of these memories.
And it's so cool that Disney
has such an expansive library.
And it's not just Disney that
you're getting access to.
Pixar, Marvel, Star Wars,
National Geographic,
and so much more.
It's sort of overwhelming,
but in the best possible way.
Disney+ is $6.99.
Or if you wanna just buy
the whole year, it's $69.99.
I'm gonna put a link in the description
where you guys can get
a seven day free trial.
Check it out
and I just wanna know what you guys think
because I have been having the best time.
I've been so busy over the past few weeks
and I've been traveling
a lot which is great
because I love watching content on flights
because that's usually my
time to just kind of hang out.
And if I don't have any videos to edit,
I'm looking for content to watch.
And what's great is you can
still have this stuff offline.
So you can download the shows
and take them on the go.
Most planes do have wifi,
but you definitely
don't wanna rely on wifi
to watch any content ever.
Just be sure to download it before I go.
And I'm sure many of you guys are probably
traveling for the holidays.
And if you're not,
I'm sure there's gonna
be some holiday downtime.
So this could not be a more perfect time
to watch a lot of content.
Another thing that is really great
is it's available on so
many different platforms.
When I was traveling back from Nashville
I knew that I had about like
a four and a half ish flight,
and this was the day that
Disney+ had launched.
So in that flight, before we took off
I watched the first
episode of The Mandalorian.
I watched Encore, I
watched Lady in the Tramp.
It was really cool to see,
because obviously I have a dog
and I love my dog more than anything.
So to see these dogs
interacting with each other
and having real, genuine
conversations and feelings.
I mean I have conversations
with my dog all the time,
but to see that in like an updated version
of Lady in the Tramp was pretty great.
I also watched The Imagineering Story.
- [Narrator] Walt set a standard early on
with The Imagineering.
- This is such a fun show
that covers a bunch of amazing
moments in Disney history.
You get to meet a lot of incredible people
who helped bring so many
creative ideas to life.
There's just so many great shows.
Another show that I was so
surprised by was Encore.
I'm not really like the
biggest fan of Broadway
or like plays.
I enjoy them, but it's not something
that I go out of my way to watch.
So in preparing for my review
I watched the first episode
and it made me almost cry.
The premise of the show
is a bunch of adults
who kind of go back to recreate
their high school plays.
The first one was Annie
and they did such a great job storytelling
because a lot of these people
obviously aren't professional actors.
So they were able to pull
so many great stories
out of these people.
Kristen Bell is one of the
executive producers of the show
so obviously I had to give it a shot
because I'm such a huge
fan of hers as well.
The second episode
is the Beauty in the Beast episode
which was also really good.
And they have all kinds of Disney movies.
I mean they even have The Simpsons.
Scrolling through to see
some of my other favorites.
They also have some cute
little Pixar shorts.
There's one where it's
Forky from Toy Story 4,
which is probably, I think,
now one of my favorite movies of all time.
Everything about Toy
Story 4 was incredible.
The story, the characters,
it's just so good.
Oh My Gosh, Zenon, Girl
of the 21st Century.
If I was able to be a
Disney star at one point,
I think this probably would've been me.
The description is "2049 and teen Zenon
"happily lives on an
orbiting space station.
"When her curiosity gets her in trouble
"she's sent to Earth for punishment
"and needs to learn how to fit in."
This is amazing
because I feel like I'm
related so much to this show.
Hannah Montana, Boy Meets
World, that's so amazing!
I think for how much you're paying
and what you're getting
this is such an amazing deal,
especially for families.
And the fact that you can just download it
and take it on the go is really great.
I also watched Turner & Hooch.
I kinda was going back to all
of the shows that I watched
when I was younger.
1989!
I was five.
I just realized that I
didn't even get a chance
to really talk about The Mandalorian yet.
I cannot believe how
incredible this show is.
I mean obviously it's Star
Wars and I love Star Wars.
I love the entire world with Star Wars.
But this show, there's
something so special about it.
I wish that I was filming my reaction
because when I got towards
the end of the first episode,
I just (gasps) could not believe my eyes
and what I was seeing.
And the best thing is
I avoided all spoilers.
I didn't read any reviews.
I wanted to go into this knowing nothing.
I didn't even watch any of the trailers.
I avoided absolutely everything,
so this experience for me was so great.
I look forward to hearing
what you reaction was to it
and I cannot wait to see what happens
in the rest of these episodes.
The character that I'm referencing
that you don't know what I'm talking about
unless you do know what I'm talking about
has made me cry every single episode.
This character is extremely cute.
That is all I'm gonna say
because I don't wanna give anything away.
But oh geez, it's amazing, it's so great.
This is kinda my first impressions.
I guess it's not really first impressions
since I've watched hours and
hours of content at this point.
And this could not be a more
perfect streaming platform
for people who are fans
of Disney and Pixar
and Star Wars and Marvel.
It has everything that we love.
Disney+ is offering people
a seven day free trial,
so I've put a link in the description
if you wanna check it out.
I'm gonna go watch the latest Encore.
See ya later.